[Applause]
a massive demonstration in Mexico City
the discontent is directed toward
Mexican president Andres Manuel Lopez
obrador's recent overhaul of the
country's independent electoral
Authority or INE
we are here to defend the INE so that
it's not modified they want us to return
to the days when the electoral system
was controlled by the government we do
not want that I need to be canceled or
modified we want it to continue so there
can be Democratic progress in Mexico
last week Congress approved a set of
sweeping reforms to the INE critics say
these changes severely cut the agency's
budget and also limit its autonomy
restricting the Inez ability to hold
political candidates who break electoral
laws accountable
political experts say that these reforms
to the National electoral Institute
represent an erosion of democracy in
Mexico arguing that it was this
electoral body that helped to end
Decades of single-party rule in Mexico
and helped to usher in a new era of
democracy for the country in the 21st
century
for his part president Lopez obrador
insists the reforms to the INE are aimed
at cutting costs and increasing
transparency he's also accused the
agency of being corrupt and favoring his
political opponents
is one of the Costless electoral
organizations in the world and also one
of the most and Democratic
though national elections in Mexico are
still a year away and Mexican presidents
are only allowed to serve a single
six-year term activists say future
elections in the country now run the
risk of being marred by distrust and
Corruption
as they were in the years before the
creation of the national electoral
Institute Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera
Mexico City